ganz Stil echt mit pumalatschen dafür
stehe ich mit meinem Namen
ja toll ich sehe so gar nicht
schwarzwaldmäßig aus Mist grüß Gott hier
ist wieder eure mahwanne ich bin heute
ganz traditionell in der Tracht
unterwegs weil wir einen Schwarzwald
Adventskalender Auspacken Schwarzwald
ich war in meinem Leben bis jetzt nur
einmal im Schwarzwald und da habe ich
jetzt auch nicht so viel von der Kultur
mitbekommen deswegen hoffe ich dieser
Kalender hilft mir einmal in den
Schwarzwald zu reisen und zu verstehen
wie diese
Schwarzwald Völkchen so tickt 100 € hat
mich dieses Teil gekostet und dieser
schwarzwaldkalender wurde vom
Schwarzwald Radio vom Hit Radio oh und
ich glaube von Europapark so ein
bisschen mit gesponsert und wo wir schon
mal beim Thema Sponsor sind dieses Video
ist gesponsortt von Sky und jetzt SH und
n dieses Video ist gespons ich wurde zum
exklusiven Screening von unser Hof mit
cheayen und Nino eingeladen und darf mir
die erste Folge anschauen dieie hier ist
ein Spinoff zu der Reality Show diese
Ochsenknechts die es ja auf Sky und so
weiter schon gab und die habe ich schon
geliebt deswegen bin ich sehr happy
eingeladen worden zu sein und freue mich
wirklich extrem drauf ich hätte ehrlich
nicht gedacht dass ich so eine reality
Maus sein kann aber ich habe diese
Ochsenknechts so gerne geschaut und
immer wenn der Hof kam war das mein
absolutes Highlight weil ich finde
cheayenne und Nino sind einfach so ein
tolles Paar und die Hochzeit oh mein
Gott die Hochzeit deswegen freue ich
mich so sehr die gleich persönlich
kennenzulernen ich gehe jetzt mal aufs
Event und dann wir sehen uns also wir
sind jetzt hier auf dem Screening sehe
ganz viele bekannte Gesichter da hinten
sitzt Nicolette em Furz und Jina also
heute ist das Who is Who der
influenzerzene ein ganz schöner Moment
für uns wir haben da sehr Herz fre mich
sehr heute alle da seid und ihr zusammen
uns die Folge heimlich guck bevor sie
morgen für alle offen ist danke
schön die neue Sky original reality Doku
unser Hof mit cheayen und Nino ab heute
auf Sky nature und auf Abruf ich habe
jetzt gerade die erste Folge gesehen von
unser Hof mit chayen und Nino und ich
muss sagen ich bin so begeistert die
Stimmung war einfach mega cool und man
kann wirklich einen richtig guten
Einblick bekommen in Landwirtschaft also
mir ist aufgefallen dass ich wirklich
gar keine Ahnung von Land und so wie der
Hof dort drüber kam ja wirkte einfach
alles sympathisch und toll und ich kann
die Serie einfach nur empfehlen und
jetzt fragt ihr euch aber Vanessa wo
können wir das ganze schauen ganz
einfach unser Hof mit cheayen und Nino
gibt es ab jetzt auf Sky und WoW und das
beste alle Folgen sind bereits online
und bereit geschaut zu werden also
natürlich nachdem ihr mein Video
geschaut habt dann könnt ihr abschalten
und direkt zu Sky oder wow rüber gehen
ne aber jetzt geht's erstmal weiter mit
dem Video ich weiß nicht was ich noch zu
diesem Kalender vorher sagen kann ich
glaube wir gehen einfach rein ich habe
keine Ahnung was uns erwartet absolut
keine Ahnung ich wei es nicht tchen
Nummer ein süß oh mein Gott ist das
niedlich ein kleiner Bambi
Keksausstecher und
orangenblütenhonig ist der Schwarzwald
bekannt für sein orangenblütenhonig
freue mich schon auf die ganzen
Kommentare von Euch
schwarzweltlern nennt man euch so na ja
die Menschen die dort leben ich möchte
alle Infos zu allen Produkten warum es
da drin ist und warum es toll ist dass
es da drin ist bzw da nicht so toll be
99 € müsste jedes Türchen ungefähr einen
Wert von 4,12 € haben ja ja also hier
muss man wirklich suchen irgendwie
wollte ich mich so schick schick in
Trachten machen aber ich sehe irgendwie
eher aus als ob ich in so ein Bierzelt
arbeiten würde und euch die Bestellung
abnehme und so richtig viele Bierkrüge
auch tragen
kann Nummer Z die sind voll gepackt
natürlich kleine Prinzessin was ist das
perlweinseo ich habe das schon in den
Kommentaren bei euch öfter jetzt gelesen
dass ihr das sehr blöd findet wenn da so
einfach Alkohol drin ist und ich muss
ehrlich sagen jetzt verstehe ich auch
warum weil also man will sich ja
eigentlich nicht spoilern deswegen guckt
man nicht was da für Produkte drin sind
dann ist da so Alkohol drin aber ich
glaube ich sag mal so bei Erwachsenen
food Kalendern ist da einfach immer
Alkohol mit drin ich glaube da ist es
dann einfach muss man das
akzeptieren den gönnen wir uns jetzt
erstmal Alkohol bitte
verantwortungsbewusst genießen
das hat Zimmertemperatur was habe ich
erwartet aber wenn es nicht
Zimmertemperatur hätte dann wäre das ein
guter Prosecco also sehr sehr lecker was
mich viel mehr wundert ist die
Kombination im Türchen Nummer 2 wir
haben hier ein Prosecco und dann ein
Fitness Dressing von Just spices was
will ich mit diesem Fitness drressing
der Schwarzwald ist so
vielseitig Mensch und ein Gutschein ich
flipp aus Türchen Nummer D ein
schwarzwaldtaler handgepackt und Versand
na toll das ist super also wenn das so
Produzenten aus der Region sind dann ist
das ja echt schön Ringelblumen Handcreme
von heiigen schwarzwällern hergestellt
das heißt heiigen könnte fleißig
[Musik]
heißen ich möchte das bitte aus jeder
Region haben kann bitte das so ein
deutsches Gesetz werden in Nummer vi die
haben den vollgestopppt in jedem Türchen
sind zwei Sachen drin oh mein Gott wie
cool Gummibärchen mit Kaffeegeschmack
das ist witzig und hier lacht mein
senfferz knoblauchsenf ich habe so viele
Senfgläser aufgemacht die noch in meinem
Kühlschrank sind die muss ich noch
aufessen ich würde so gerne probieren
ich probi ich habe so Bock drauf einmal
kurz
weggucken lecker leckerer Senf da spüle
ich doch glatt noch mal mit meinem
Proseco nach tüchen Nummer 5 ich bin
hier sind immer zwei Produkte drin das
auch aus dem Schwarz eine Gesichtsmaske
und viel zu große fl Spätburgunder
Rotwein ja
toll Weinmanufaktur gäenbach Offenburg
falls ihr diesen Rotwein kennt könnt ihr
mir bitte eine richtig professionelle
Analyse vom Geschmack in die Kommentare
schreiben vielen Dank ich werde jetzt
nicht noch dies rotweinmchen diese
kaffeegummibärchen lachen mich so
an ein bisschen hart das ist so verrückt
das ist wie bei den bettybots Boden die
sehen ja nicht nach diesem Geschmack aus
und dann kommt da plötzlich so ein
Geschmack den man überhaupt nicht
erwartet Ohrenschmalz schmeck einfach
nach Milchkaffee friegt auch komplett
nach Kaffe Türchen Nummer 6 es ist
Nikolaus und wir schauen was in unserem
Adventskalender drin
ist kennt ihr noch Campino Sahne Moment
ein Campino sahn war so die Werbung also
ich würd es nicht glauben wenn ich es
nicht probiert hätte stehen die
schwarzwäer sehr auf Kaffee hier ist
nämlich wieder Kaffeegeschmack drin die
sehen genauso aus nur das die früher so
nee die haben auch so
Streifen okay das muss mir wirklich
manand erklären stehen die schwarzw auf
Kaffee was gibt es hier dazu
Schwarzkirsche
Essig die Kombinationen machen ja gar
keinen Sinn also das ist jetzt schon
klar es sind einfach immer zwei Produkte
ich glaube Sie haben es einfach so
gemacht um zu gucken dass es passt ja es
ist halt ein regionaler wie soll man
sonst sortieren ne das ist verrückt
Nummer s hier ist nur ein Produkt drin
sorry aber unsere Erwartungshaltung ist
ein bisschen gestiegen da fühle ich mich
jetzt enttäuscht
oh Black Forest Black Forest klingt so
viel als Schwarzwald Gin aus Black
Forest hier unten steht Black Forest den
werde ich definitiv nicht probierenpick
schwarzwelder Fichtennadeln machen
diesen fruchtig Würz Schwarzwälder
fichttennadeln sind hier drin das ist
ein regionaler Adventskalender Nummer
ich war kurz erschrocken apfelmertisch
sieht ein zu ein aus wie
knoblauchsenf und hier gibt wieder
was Fichte Granatapfel die XM Edition
der bärenkpanie company kenne ich gibt
aber auch in Hamburg und so aber die
kommen aus dem Schwarzwald nee kalfani
süße Werbung kommt aus dem
Schwarzwald was oh mein Gott ist das
cool das sind teegummibärchen Bärchen
die du mit heißem Wasser auflöst und
dann hast du ein Tee hier lernt man echt
noch was
dazu ich find sowas cool ich möchte
manchmal was anderes machen einfach mal
was neues erleben kaffeegummibärchen
Essen und teebeären Trinken okay ich
habe hohe Erwartungen an das Türchen
Nummer 9 denn Türchen Nummer 9 ist das
beste Türchen we meine Lieblingszahl ist
und dieser Kalender finde ich überzeugt
mich bis jetzt ganz gut Türchen Nummer
ne9 let's go ist das denn advent Advent
bereits die dritte Kerze brennt Heilig
Abend steht vor der Tür und wir möchten
uns jetzt schon bei dir bei ih für das
zurückliegen habe ich die richtige
Türchen ja advent Advent bereits das
dritte Kerzchen brennt
oh ich glaube die haben sich hier
verpackt das dritte Kerzchen brennt am
17 und das ist hier hier ist das neunte
Türchen und ich habe ein Zettel drin
bekommen Advent Advent das dritte
Kerzchen brennt sorry ich bin verwirrt
das hier ist ein weggglas hier steht
wegverlag man kriegt ein Heft gratis
gibt von den wegggläsern einen
Verlag okay und hier ist werbe
Werbegeschenk Gummibärchen drin ja
anscheintend haben die wegläer auch ein
Heft
gratis ist wahrscheinlich einfach das 17
Türchen was ich hier bei Nummer 9
aufgemacht habe fängt der Schwarzwald
Adventskalender anzubröckeln das finden
wir raus in Türchen Nummer 10 in Türchen
Nummer 10 ein H
klammerset hier sind einfach
Haarklammern drin ein klimaneutrales
Produkt
hergestellt mit dem schnellen
nachwachsenden Rohstoff Stroh warum lit
überhaupt Stroh das sind Haarklammern
die fühlen sich wie Plastik an sind aber
aus Stroh und noch ein kleines Geschenk
das ist ja zuckersüß was soll denn das
für ein Glas sein Werkstatt am Salmen
bei Vorlage dieses Gutscheins erhalten
Sie 10% Rabatt auf Ihren nächsten
Einkauf Werkstatt am Salmen da erhält
man einfach Geschenke zu jeden Anlass
super das ist so süß s FLI aus man
kriegt ein 10% Gutschein hier Nummer
okay da wird hier der Schnaps wird dir
groß geschrieben Wald Himbeergeist ich
bin jetzt nicht der größte himbeerfan
40przentiger Alkohol gar kein Problem
den oh mann das ist so eine richtige
Flasche wie so Opa die so rausolt so ich
habe uns jetzt hier noch mal ein STF
mitgenommen die wollen mich einfach
schocken gummibächer mit lavende
lavende könnten die Gummibärchen ein
dann auch entspannen also dieser
Kalender ist einfach König von
random lavende das Problem ist ich
benutze lavendeel viel zu oft für
antiwespenschutz
antimottenschutz im Kleiderschrank
ätherisches Öl auftragen wenn ich
anxiety habe das zu essen fühlt sich
irgendwie falsch an obwohl es lecker ist
wir sind bei tüche Nummer 12 und das
bedeutet Halbzeit und das Türchen Nummer
12 sieht witzig cool
also mein absolutes Highlight wenn mich
jetzt noch mal vom Radio oder von der
Zeitung jemand anfragt über
Adventskalender zu sprechen werde ich
sagen dass das das Produkt 2023 aus den
Adventskalendern
[Musik]
ist fantastische Halbzeit und jetzt geht
es weiter mit tüch Nummer 13 oh großes
Glas Erdbeermarmelade wandgerührt hä
also die erdbeen werden an die Wand
geklatscht und dann rührt man an der
Wand und dann hat man erdbemarmelade
Hand gerührt woll schon sagen was ist
denn wandgerührt wandgerührte ermmelade
14 irgendwie frech wenn nur ein Produkt
drin ist obwohl das absolut nicht der
Standard ist fü ich mich jetzt so als ob
da so zwei drin sein müssten
schwarzwaldradio ist hier ein kleines
Radio drin saftige Schokokekse nein die
Schachtel h nicht gebraucht ich meine
das ist doch Verpackung genug und das
ist Gewürz Großmutters schokogeheimnis
gewürzzubereitung na ja ein schokogewürz
gucken wir mal ja es riecht irgendwie
nach einem Lebkuchen ein schokoladigen
Lebkuchen 15 noch etwas von der
schwarzwaldwürze das ist wirklich eine
einmal Portion Brathähnchen Gewürzsalz
es riecht extrem lecker kann auch daran
liegen dass ich Hunger habe ich liebe
diesen Kalender ich finde diesen
Kalender so toll so schmeckt bei uns im
Schwarzwald 40 regionale
schwarzwaldrezepte fledleuppe kenne ich
auch aus dem Schwabenland aber
vielleicht ist das auch so ungefähr
gleiche Region badische schneckenüle
ganz super ganz fantastisch Nummer
16 was zur Hölle ich wollte gerade sagen
wird das im Schwarzwald hergestellt aber
nee das kommt aus nordersted das kommt
aus meiner Ecke nicht aus dem
Schwarzwald Leute dieser Kalender wird
immer besser natürlich braucht man das
doch zum Geschenke verpacken und die
haben jetzt einfach ein teserfm mit
diesem tollen Portionierer dass man sich
das so schön abziehen kann mit zwei
original teser ich bin verwirrt ich bin
so verwirrt aber positiv und eine
Anti-Aging Tagescreme Probe fantastisch
ist da einfach teser drin ich kann nicht
mehr dieser Kalender ist ist
fantastisch oh ich ich freue mich schon
ich ich weiß das ist doch verrückt Apfel
zimtcookies aus so einer Dose ich dachte
das ist jetzt so ein Fleisch
drin sind zwei Apfel Zimt Cookies drin
ich probi
mal da ist total viel Apfel
drin ist das geil okay ab jetzt bewerte
ich nicht mehr ich genieß nur noch Tür
Nummer 18 und da hat Opa noch mal sein
Schnäppchen se zweiten rausgepackt der
Schwarzwald Aronia Likör Aronia finde
ich toll und das hat hier nicht 40%
sondern 25% Leute trinkt Alkohol
verantwortungsbewusst 100% Baden steht
da drauf hier sind drei Produkte drin
augenmaskenpads und natürlich hat der
Schwarzwald auch sein eigenes Duschgel
ist doch klar hätte gern diesen Hut mit
den Kugeln drauf weil ja ich weiß ich
habe eine Tracht angezogen das ist nicht
typisch schwarzweiß ich sehe nicht aus
wie diese junge Dame ich will halt
diesen flauscheball Hut Nummer 19 jetzt
kommen sie aber auch mit ihren Dosen
jetzt wollen sie zeigen was sie alles in
Dosen reinmachen können ja gen
leberwurstdose ich e keine Leberwurst
ich esse auch kein Schweinefleisch ich
muss dafür ein Abnehmer finden
aber t Kalender mit leberwur eint 20 von
der rubinmühle BI sportmüsli 21 ich kann
es nicht glauben was hier so drin ist
ich Flip do aus das ist noch ein
Kugelschreiber ich Flip doch a ist das
unpraktischer Kugelschreiber aber es ist
okay denn er sieht aus bzw sieht ja
nicht me aus das ist ja
ja das war mal ein
Ast ein Kugelschreiber dieser Kalender
ist so toll ich kann es nicht in Worte
fassen Türchen
22 wirklich nicht euer Ernst ist so
lustig da machen wir d schwarzw
Servietten drauf und die kriegt und die
die Uhr bekommt auch noch mal diesen
kugelhut das ist ein tolles Design
schwarzweierten vorletztes Türchen ich
bin ich kann mehr s ich bin einfach
nur in dem dauerschockzustand Nummer 23
vorletztes Türchen und wir haben
natürlich noch meine Dose hier drin ist
doch klar passend dazu dass morgen
Heilig Abend ist
Stollenkonfekt ja das meine nicht auf
das ist bestimmt auch Milch drin ja
Laktose ja das werde ich jemandem geben
der das auch wirklich aufessen kann aber
es ist einfach verückt und jetzt kommt
der Moment jetzt kommt der Moment auf
dem wir wirklich gewartet haben denn ich
kann mir gar nicht vorstellen was hier
zu Weihnachten drin sein soll es könnte
wirklich alles sein t Nummer
24 hast du deine fituhr ja die habe ich
aus meinem Schwarzwald Adventskalender
emporia fit basic fitnessuhr hier kann
man aber wirklich sagen falls man noch
kein Weihnachtsgeschenk für jemanden an
dem Tag hat macht man sein Kalender auf
und ist so
ja genau das habe ich gebraucht oh m ich
dachte ich gewinne ein goldenes Ticket
mit Chance auf ein goldenes Ticket z.B
Europapark Karten Hotelgutscheine und
viele mehr Gewinnchance ca 1
Z75 ich gebe noch nicht auf mein
goldenes Ticket ist bestimmt nur
verrutscht nein leider doch nicht leider
nein leider gar nicht ich hätte es
niemals erwartet dieser Kalender ist
jetzt keine Offenbarung oder so aber
irgendwie ist er mir so sympathisch für
99 € bekommt man hier wirklich le
schwarzwaldpodukte
und das sage ich dazu ich weiß nicht ja
ja sind 4 € pro Türchen ungefähr falls
ihr aus dem Schwarzwald seid gibt mal
gerne auch noch mal eure Meinung ob das
wirklich so ein schöner authentischer
Kalender der Schwarzwald gut
repräsentiert wurde ich finde aber hier
waren so viele so random witzige Artikel
drin dieser Holzstift diese Gummibärchen
die zu Tee werden lieberwurst und hier
ist vor allem für alle was dabei dieser
Kalender ist für keine Personen speziell
angerichtet man muss an dieser Stelle
wissen ob man 99 € für ein
Adventskalender ausgeben möchte und dann
hat man netten Adventskalender super wir
sehen uns dann beim nächsten Mal wieder
Danke Sky für die tolle Kooperation und
schaut unbedingt unser Hof mit chayen
und Nino bis
dann welchen Adventskalender willst du
dieses Jahr haben Bo das mir auf jeden
Fall nicht den einen influencer Kalender
den du hattest letztens let ich nicht
den nam sag oh okay t alles klar gut das
bleibt ein Geheimnis bis dann